education news now the tech industry
including areas in automotive and
computer coding continues to be male
dominated but as 8 news now reported
this is the Clark County high school
that is doing some great work in helping
younger students see their possibilities
the Southwest Career and Technical
Academy right here in the valley is
empowering their female students through
a girls in Tech day showcasing them the
different things they can do and usually
male-dominated fields
it's really fun so far I would this is
like a really fun school year Aubry
Knowlton is one of dozens of middle
school students visiting the school
Tuesday to get first-hand experience in
Automotive
coding well I do code I like to follow
the directions the first time and then
switch it after that but you can do what
you want and graphic design workshops
yeah
that is the good good Zone with the goal
of showing them at different possible
career paths as early as high school you
can't aspire to be something that you
don't know exists so if we never show
you
something how would you know you wanted
to be it throughout the day the students
learned how to write code design a video
game character and even change a tire on
a car a lot of like girls feel
discouraged to like cars because of
societal Norms so I think it's a very
big thing to like show these girls like
hey boys can do it but we can too the
students I spoke to today took a big
interest in the automotive and coding
that they learned today and the school
says they'll continue this program for
years to come in the valley for eight
news now I'm Brian will